le Macron est évidemment responsable et
coupable et Édouard Philippe avec lui
quand j'entends Emmanuel Macron dire sur
Fessenheim qu'on ne vienne pas me
chercher mais quelle irresponsabilité
scandaleuse quand j'entends Édouard
Philippe nous dire
aimer ne pas fermer Fessenheim mais
pardon mais qui était au responsabilité
il était évidemment possible de ne pas
fermer cette centrale qui représente des
milliers d'éoliennes à elle toute seule
donc on peut si vous voulez s'engager
dans une espèce de vision mythologique
de la transition énergétique à la fin ce
qui compte c'est de revenir à la
rationalité si on ne produit pas
vraiment je termine mais le manque
d'investissement sur le nucléaire c'est
pas uniquement Emmanuel Macron ah non
c'est aussi François Hollande je vous
l'accorde parfaitement la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron a prolongé et aggravé
celle de la gauche au pouvoir même
François Hollande n'avait pas osé même
la gauche au pouvoir parce qu'elle avait
encore un peu de sens de la continuité
républicaine n'avait pas osé nommer au
ministère chargé de l'énergie des
ministres anti-nucléaires il n'y a
qu'Emmanuel Macron qui est fait ça
Nicolas Hulot François de Rugy barbara
Pompili trois ministres de l'énergie
trois ministres anti-nucléaires quand le
parti commun lui-même sait que au fond
le pacte français a reposé beaucoup sur
ce choix d'investissement stratégique
qui s'est révélé d'une actualité
incroyable avec la crise climatique qui
était le parc nucléaire français donc
oui évidemment Emmanuel Macron a
prolongé la politique de François
Hollande il aurait pu la changer il est
responsable de ce choix stratégique et
je pense que d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui nous sommes devant les
conséquences des choix faits pendant ces
10 dernières années si les Français vont
manquer d'électricité cet hiver si les
prix de l'électricité sont en train
d'exploser les Français ne le voient pas
parce que le bouclier tarifaire fait que
c'est leurs enfants qui vont le payer
mais les entreprises les PME les TPE les
artisans les agriculteurs tous le voient
très bien les factures d'électricité
explosent et bien ça c'est la
conséquence des politiques menées au
cours des 10 dernières années et on peut
changer toutes les règles du marché
qu'on voudra on ne change pas les
premiers principes de l'économie et le
premier principe de l'économie c'est que
tout ce qui est rare est cher